nb energy has been working hard to
restore power in a number of areas at
this hour close to 3 000 people still
without power as we take a look at this
map the outages are spread out across
the valley out as far as lake mead a lot
also happening in the central valley
even along the strip madison kimbrough
live tonight with a look at it madison
yeah here on the northern end of the
strip is where people are seeing the
most outages as wind and rain take
center stage tonight
from the sahara hotel to the strat the
newly built vegas gateway arches which
are completely blacked out traffic
lights are down as well causing people
to take it slow when driving today's
winds reached a high of over 60 miles
per hour causing major delays at the
airport along with traffic out on the
roadways here's what some people near
the strat had to say about the outages
and today's weather it don't feel like
vegas it's kind of damping in the mood
the lights went out and then we have
this crazy like sand storm all day and
all this crazy wind then it gets like
really cold it's kind of creepy in a way
well i could tell when i was looking
outside the window from where i worked
that other places were starting to lose
power too several guests at the strat
say their rooms were without power but
thanks to backup generators the casino
area was still active
currently nv energy is working hard to
restore power with expected revival in
the next couple hours we've already seen
a couple of these areas here these
stores light up with power once again so
that is a relief and they are expected
to get even more power within the next
coming hours like i just mentioned
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now